when I tried it I felt better that I
read so I just kept on doing it
why I don't know I thought we were
closer than most fathers and sons this
isn't us this is not who we are both of
you stop
there are moments that I look at him and
I wonder who he is
how's that boy David I'm not giving up
now never
[Music]
you always gotta be controlling
everything doesn't make any sense you
control me right now let us help you I
don't want you how about you understand
that I had such grand plans you'd
graduate from college do something
amazing and now I just wanted to not die
who are you Nick this isn't me that here
this is Who I am
if you could take all the words in the
language it's still in describing each
other I love you more than everything
I'm really sorry it's hard as hell to
get sober but I love my family I want to
be proud of me
[Music]
I understand how scared you are it'll
pass though it always does
Mack what you have is extraordinary
and you're gonna get it back you're
gonna find it again
you